financial literacy in this country or
the lack of it has become a huge issue
in our country in fact it's become a
national economic issue so much so that
President Bush just recently in January
created the presidential Council on
financial literacy with advisors from
all you know from all backgrounds the
prof for-profit nonprofit area the left
financial literacy right now is
something that affects Americans from
all walks of life you know it affects
you it affects our colleagues our
friends our neighbors and it's not blind
to gender or socioeconomic status and so
Congress created are deemed April
Financial Literacy Month because it's an
issue that we need to create more
awareness and more ownership for within
the family and within the workplace
you